- [Narrator] Hi, everyone.
In this video,
we are going to be talking about
one of the most fascinating
and complex features
of life on Earth, cells.
But before we do,
I'd like to take us way back
to when I was a little kid.
Now I know that for me, at least,
I had a great time playing
with toy building blocks,
and creating things out of them.
I used blocks of
different shapes and sizes
to make all kinds of things like houses,
cars, even spaceships, and airplanes.
You're probably thinking,
what does this have to do with cells?
Well, cells are considered
the building blocks of life.
Like my blocks, cells can
come in a variety of shapes,
and they have different features too.
They can also stand alone,
or they can come together
to build something larger.
So let's dive deeper into this
fascinating topic of cells.
So all living things, or organisms,
like you, me, your pet dog,
the birds in the sky, the fish in the sea,
all organisms are made of
these basic units called cells.
Take this moss plant, for
example, if we zoom way in,
we can see that it's actually
made up of many smaller units.
These units are cells.
Each cell contains a flurry of activity,
as it works to carry out the functions
that keep the organism alive.
In fact, cells are the smallest
unit that can carry out
all the tasks necessary for life.
For instance, all cells can
take up nutrients and water,
get rid of waste, use energy,
and interact with the things around them
in their environment.
These functions, plus many
others that cells carry out,
are what make life possible.
There are many different kinds of cells.
For instance, take a look at these cells
that make up an onion's outer skin,
or these really cool red blood cells,
or even these bacterial cells.
This type of bacteria is called e-coli,
which you might've heard
can be a safety hazard
found in our food.
So cells are fascinating to look at,
but we generally can't see
them with our eyes alone.
Most cells are so small
that we need a microscope to see them.
In fact, all of these
pictures of cells here
were taken with the aid of microscopes.
And something else that I find really cool
is that some organisms are
made up of only a single cell,
while others are made up of many cells.
So organisms that are made up of one cell
are called unicellular,
and organisms that are
made up of many cells
are called multicellular.
Uni telling us that
there is only one cell,
and multi telling us that
there are many cells.
So an example of a unicellular organism
would be the e-coli bacteria
that I mentioned a minute ago.
Each bacterium is a single cell
that's responsible for taking
in nutrients, reproducing,
and doing all the things
that it needs to stay alive.
So an example of a multicellular organism
would be you, me, or
most any other organism
that you can see with the naked eye.
And the cells of multicellular organisms
are often specialized to
carry out specific functions.
So for example,
some cells help the
organism absorb nutrients,
while others transmit information,
or defend against bacteria and viruses.
So going back to our comparison
between building blocks and cells,
specialized cells are like
different building blocks
of different sizes, shapes, and colors.
And these different blocks
can come together to
build something larger,
like this airplane here.
Similarly, cells with different structures
and functions come together
to make something larger,
an organism like this
adorable kitten right here.
So to sum up cells and organisms,
today, we learned that cells
are the smallest unit of life.
We talked about how all
organisms are made up of cells,
and that organisms can be
unicellular or multicellular.
So I hope that now you
have a good understanding
of cells and organisms,
as well as a new perspective
about building blocks,
not the toys, but the cells
that make up life itself.